most people will only see a carpet of
trash here
daniel bucher sees a scandal in
thailand's landfills nearly two-thirds
of the waste is organic
mostly food waste on the surface this
all looks like plastic waste
but when you look inside as well as this
soft gooey stuff down there
it's all food organic organic it's
biomass
these still look quite okay they're well
packed you could probably wash them and
make something with them
[Music]
originally from germany daniel bucher is
head chef in a bangkok hotel
food and reducing food waste is
important to him
i personally hate throwing food away not
only because when i've cooked something
i've put a lot of care
and attention into it but also because
it just seems utterly idiotic to throw
something away that's clearly edible
it's always bothered me and it drives me
nuts
found in the hotel with over a thousand
rooms
it's one of the biggest in thailand he's
planted a vegetable garden on the roof
of the hotel for his 200 staff
its yield is negligible compared to the
hotel's needs
but the project has raised his staff's
awareness of the life of food
the way we carelessly throw things away
is a result of our seeing food
merely as a product we're not aware of
how difficult it is to actually plant
something
and how long the path is from the seed
in the soil to the edible produce
bucha says storing food correctly is key
something he always thought was obvious
but he's found many people ignore
even some of the most basic principles
things like drying washed vegetables to
help them keep longer
every day hygiene teams check the food
in the hotel's pantries to make sure
it's fresh
if you have a bell pepper which is going
soft in a box like this
a whole part of the box can turn very
quickly and then it has to be thrown
away
says hotels waste food in part because
the chefs have to work at a fast pace
so he set up a central kitchen in his
hotel where many of the leftovers can be
put to good use
we collect all the leftovers from
preparation the unused ends of
vegetables or meat
at the various carveries in the hotel
there are always the bones left over
we collect them to make stock with
normally you wouldn't bother
if you only used one onion but when
you've sliced hundreds of onions
there's enough for a stock
this hotel boasts six different
specialty restaurants
there's also a buffet area with a
variety of different stations for
preparing various dishes
with a bit of supervision and planning
he's able to keep
waste to a minimum
the boiled eggs left over from breakfast
all land in there
it's a midday favorite people really
like eating it
and we don't have to boil the eggs in it
the problem is that breakfast eggs are
cooked in the western kitchen
but this is chinese cuisine
ideas like this have helped bucha and
his team cut their hotel's food waste in
half
over just two years it wasn't easy
there was a learning curve and a lot of
workflows had to be changed
once you've got things working it's easy
and runs automatically
once a month bucha and his team take
stock
they take a look at what food has gone
unused that day
and how it could be transformed into
gourmet cuisine
everyone let's go let's go
you can take this salmon for instance we
take the head it was baked in a salt
crust
and make soups out of it it goes into
the japanese breakfast soup
this you can break up and in the evening
we're doing pasta
so we can do that with salmon and
spinach
food that is still good to eat that the
hotel can't use
is donated to an ngo its staff collect
the leftovers each day
and distribute them to people in need
across the city
only perishables containing things like
fish or cream end up in the bin
though even then not till they've been
weighed and registered
this helps us to better understand what
we're throwing away and how much
we always compile our monthly report
then we can see exactly how much it is
and maybe manage to reduce it a little
and if i want to know where we're
focusing on next or what's next to be
tackled
then we use that data to say okay these
are the areas where we have to save in
where we have a problem
data collection can be a good way to
discover new solutions to old problems
like the problem of food waste the
german agency for international
cooperation
giz is funding a study to examine the
waste produced by 400 representative
households across
thailand this kind of information hasn't
been collected before
in part because the costs for garbage
disposal here are levied at a flat rate
and not according to volume or weight
you wouldn't get any vision we want to
know how much garbage gets sorted and
separated
where it goes to and what happens to it
it's hoped that this data will help
discover ways to reduce
food waste food that ends up in
landfills
isn't just wasteful it's also terrible
for the climate
when organic matter rots it releases
methane gas
a powerful greenhouse gas that's
estimated to be 25 times more potent
than co2
so organic waste is a real climate
killer especially in developing
economies which rarely have modern
recycling or composting technology for
daniel bucher the solution is clear
we often talk about what to do with all
the waste and their important debates
but we should really be talking about
how we can prevent these trash piles
from building up in the first place
daniel bucher wants to lead by example
he knows that every step forward
will make a difference
you